So Leute da bin ich schon mal wieder, letzter Stream ist ja schon ein paar Tage her, wenn
ich das richtig sehe, mal kurz gucken, naja drei Tage, hältst du dich in Grenzen, das
lütt ich ewig her, drei Tage, Pog, Small Access Point auch am Start, der jetzt Small ist
mittlerweile, Melonman auch am Start, Pog, Hyper Pog Leute, wollt ihr mal Vorschau für
die neuen Twitch Emotes sehen, vielleicht sollte ich da mal kurz warten bis noch mehr
Leute da sind, ich zeige euch gleich die Vorschau für neue Twitch Emotes, aber die sind noch
nicht fertig, da fehlen noch ein paar Customizations, du hast gerade das Video zum Mittagessen gesehen,
Mittagessen ist ein gutes Stichwort, ich habe richtig viel Nudel gerade gefressen, ich
war heute Morgen wieder zwei Stunden unterwegs, diesmal war es auch saumäßig kalt, 0, 1,
2 Grad so, irgendwie hat ein bisschen geschwankt, war sogar Schnee auf den Bäumen, es war wirklich
übelst kalt, Wind geweht, da habe ich wahrscheinlich nochmal doppelt viele Kalorien gebraucht
bei den zwei Stunden, ich habe gerade richtig viel Nudel gefressen, zwei Teller gehäuft
voll mit Nudel, Tomatensoße, Hackfleisch und dann noch beim zweiten Teller, als ich
gemerkt habe, ich bin noch nicht satt, habe ich noch massig Parmesan Käse drauf geschmissen,
dass irgendwie satt wird, aus Versehen beim Sprechen auf ein Mikrofon gespuckt, Monka
Disgusting, Ups, ist mein Handy runtergefallen, was ist denn jetzt los hier auf einmal, was
ist denn hier los Mensch, oh Handy muss ich aufladen sehe ich gerade, 27% nur noch, geht
ja nicht, bei euch gab es auch noch, was gab es dabei, aus irgendwelchen Gründen habe
ich keinen Chat bei mir im Vorschau Bild, da ist er aber wieder, ja geht doch, ach das
ist mal Twitch mit der irgendwas geändert hat an der Seite, ich kann sagen der Chat ist
irgendwie nicht richtig bei mir in der Vorschau, aber ok, na gut Sahne Hackfleischsoße, ja
das andere verkehrt, wie gesagt ich habe ganz klassisch Tomatensoße, Tomatesoße, in Hessen
sagen wir, Tomatesoße, ja dann würde ich sagen, du kannst ja das Video nebenbei laufen
lassen, dass ich Viewtime bekomme, vielleicht soll ich mal meine Emotes ordentlich resize,
a weird champ, heute werden wir wahnsinnig agil sein, ich habe nämlich mittlerweile 5
Issues in meinem GitHub Repo für meinen Heim Automatisierungs Home Assistant Addon, 5 offene
Issues, da müssen wir ein paar bearbeiten, dass das mal wieder hier ordentlicher aussieht,
ich glaube aber die meisten sind gar nicht so kompliziert, ich muss erstmal meine Vm
nebenbei updaten, das schmeißen wir jetzt mal schnell an, weil bis die Vm geupdatet
ist, das dauert eh wieder, dann ist der Chat kaputt in OBS, kann das sein, dann ist der
Chat in OBS kaputt, wollen wir Patrick C++, oh das müssen wir wahrscheinlich auch demnächst
noch mal machen, wir müssen ein bisschen ESP basteln, ist der Chat kaputt, ist, achja der
Chat war kaputt, schon gewundert, warum ich da nichts sehe, na jetzt ist alles da, sehr
schön, ja also gut jetzt sind da ein paar Leute da, Leute wollt ihr mal Vorschau für
neue Twitch Emotes sehen, ich weiß ich bin da nicht sonderlich schnell, aber ich hab jetzt
welche beauftragt, ich mach mal nebenbei Update, ich zeig euch mal, ich zeig euch mal Vorschau,
wie gesagt ist noch nicht ganz fertig, fehlen noch ein paar Anpassungen, aber so ganz grob
finde ich sind die schon mal wieder richtig nice geworden, ich zeig's euch mal schnell,
während ich hier Update mach, ja da soll man im Hintergrund Update machen, ich zeig's
euch mal kurz, also wo hab ich denn das Bild, da, alles klar, hier, das ist so der erste
Entwurf für neue Emotes, der hier kriegt noch blonde Haare, der kriegt noch blonde
Haare, weil das soll ein Aja Ja Emote werden, der kriegt noch blonde Haare, es gibt einen
Giga Chat Keks, es gibt einen fetten Keks und es gibt Betke, mal schauen, ob das wenn man
das resized in klein noch gut ausschaut, Betke, das hab ich auch gesagt, Patrick genau das,
ich hab hier zwei Sachen geschrieben heute, die Bettdecke muss bei Betke, das erkennt
man das halt richtig, die Emotes sind ja am Ende nur noch so groß, bei Betke muss auf
jeden Fall zugedeckt werden und nicht dahinter haben und der hier braucht blonde Haare und
muss eigentlich noch etwas entusiastischer Aja Ja machen, der fette Keks den finde ich
wiederum richtig nice, ich bin mir bloß nicht ganz sicher ob man das richtig erkennt, das
sieht fast aus als hat er Titten, in klein, dabei sind das Backen, das ist quasi die Kombination
dann aus Pepo Fett und Buba, sagt aber in klein sieht es wirklich aus, als hätte es
hier oben, naja, aber ist erstmal in, wie sagt man, Work in Progress, schau wie es am
Ende aussieht, aber die hat auch die ganzen letzten Emotes gemacht, also die die es in
groß gibt, der Chain Law hat ja ein paar kleine gebaut, aber die ganzen größeren Emotes Keks
und sind alle von der, was heißt die macht das auch gut, Painstalls ja, ich hab euch
gerade mal neue Entwürfe für Emotes gezeigt, ich hab ja noch 20 Emote Slots oder sowas
und ne gar so viel sind's jetzt, 15 glaube ich, 15 Emote Slots insgesamt, wenn man noch
Tier 2 dabei rechnet, Tier 2 und 3, wir könnten noch viel viel mehr Emotes haben, aktuell
haben wir ja kaum welche, ich glaube ich hab einmal Emotes geadded und es wars dann, easy
money Subs, so schauen wir mal kurz was hier die, oh die Updates sind fertig, das ging
jetzt aber schneller als ich gedacht hab, tatsächlich, zack nochmal Develop Packages
Updaten, das hier machen wir mal alles zu, das machen wir auch zu, alles mal zu, da haben
wir doch schon gleich das Richtige offen, jaja alles dicht, ich muss jetzt eh gleich
Rebooten, so JetBrains Tools, Postman, Visual Studio Code, jawoll alles Updaten, Gibby,
alles Updaten, das ganze JetBrains Zeug noch Updaten gleich, moin Drachenflieger und dann
zeige ich euch was wir heute machen, wie gesagt, ich kann mich jetzt schon mal einloggen, oh
wir brauchen euren Fiat Fake Account vermute ich mal, komm mal wenn man hier unter Issues
guckt gibt's ein paar Probleme anscheinend, das erste was wir uns heute angucken ist das
hier, also das machen wir auch irgendwann mal im Stream, also das hier ist eigentlich
gefixt, das hier könnte ich eigentlich, ich muss mich mal einloggen gleich, das hier könnte
ich eigentlich fast schließen, so das machen wir irgendwann im anderen Stream, was wir heute
machen ist das hier, also es gibt verschiedene Probleme und zwar das erste ist, dass irgendwelche
Leute auf die Idee kommen, man sollte das Home Assistant addon oder man könnte das Home
Assistant addon ja ohne Home Assistant verwenden, wobei das ist so nicht ganz richtig, man könnte
das Home Assistant addon ohne das, ohne den Home Assistant mit dem Addon Manager verwenden,
also quasi Raw Home Assistant selbst installiert in einem Container verwenden die Leute und
nicht den fertigen der quasi einen Addon Manager und sowas mitbringt, so und die wollen das
irgendwie in einem eigenen Container verwenden, deswegen habe ich mir gedacht wir könnten,
wir könnten theoretisch, also selbst kannst du es vergessen, es ist total eklig, da plickt
keiner durch, ich habe mir gedacht wir machen es uns total einfach und sowas, ne ne wir machen
nicht close one fix, ich glaube es ist sogar relativ einfach zu fixen, ich habe auch schon
geschrieben dass es eigentlich nicht richtig geht, aber wieso, naja, du kannst Home Assistant
auf zig Arten installieren, eine davon ist Home Assistant OS, Musik ist ein bisschen
laut oder, Dankeschön für den Zapp, Musik ist ein wenig aufträglich gerade, komm wir
machen mal irgendwie, nimm mal hier, Chillstep Mix 2022, hört zwar sonst keiner mehr, aber
das ist immer entspannend hier, exellent, Michael FK sowieso, gib ihm, wupp wupp wupp,
jawoll wupp wupp wupp, gut, alles klar, also wenn du Home Assistant installierst, da gibt
es ja verschiedene Varianten, Selfmade Ice, Dankeschön für den Zapp, es gibt die einfachste
Variante und das ist sich den hier ISO runter zu laden und fertig, das ISO packst du dann
entweder auf den Raspberry Pi oder in eine 4M und so und fertig ist, da ist dann auch
ein Addon Manager dabei und alles, so und man kann es aber auch selbst Standalone als
Python Virtual Environment oder als eigener Docker Container betreiben und die Leute betreiben
das hier als eigener Docker Container und wollen quasi auch meinen Addon als eigenen
Docker Container betreiben, nicht als Addon, so und ne die Parts hab ich noch nicht bestellt,
ich hab auch letztens nochmal überlegt, ob ich mir nicht vielleicht doch nur einen 13.700
Hohle und dafür nen Luftkühler, ich bin da immer noch nicht ganz sicher, aber die Woche,
also die nächste Woche, die kommende Woche muss ich das bestellen, sonst wird das nix,
so und ich hab mir gedacht, wir könnten das tatsächlich sogar relativ einfach supporten,
was sie vorhaben, das Startscript vom Addon sieht aktuell so aus, das macht eigentlich
nichts anderes, wie Environment Variablen setzen, ja MQTT, User, Passwort, Server, Port,
ja, das setzt eigentlich nur Environment Variablen, sonst nix großartig, aber es holt sich das
halt aus der Config für das Home Assistant Addon raus und das haben die Leute ja nicht,
deswegen hab ich mir gedacht, wir machen das ganz simpel, wir machen hier einfach nen if,
so if Standalone oder sowas, da muss man eben ne Variable exportieren, die Standalone heißt,
if Standalone oder if not Standalone, dann macht er das, else nimmt er halt die Environment
Variablen, die irgendein Typ in seiner Docker Compose Datei gesetzt hat, fertig, ob man das
hier schöner machen kann, bin ich mir übrigens auch nicht ganz sicher, also der Sinn davon
ist ja folgender, er guckt, ob das hier gesetzt ist, genau, also der guckt, ob das hier gesetzt
ist, wenn das nicht gesetzt ist, dann überschreibt das mit dem User aus der Addon Config, also nee,
nee, nee, nee, nee, dann holt er sich den auto generated User, genau, also es ist, dass man
im Prinzip den MQTT Server überschreiben kann, wenn man dann extern verwenden will, keine Ahnung,
ob man das irgendwie schöner machen kann in Bash, naja, ja, also das gucken wir uns heute an,
also das ist das erste Issue, oh, was ist hier los, Exit, warum, warum hat er geexited,
ach, ich glaube, ich habe nicht rechtzeitig mein Sudo Passwort eingegeben, kann das sein,
ich habe bestimmt, ich habe bestimmt das Sudo, ja, genau, Sudo Passwort vergessen,
Chat Addon kaputt, nee, warum, funktioniert doch alles, es hat eben schon mal ein bisschen
rumgesponnen mit dem Chat, aber bei mir in der Vorschau ist alles drin, Leute, nachdem ich das
Video gestern hochgeladen habe, ich habe noch mal zwei neue Jobangebote per Mail bekommen,
das ist schon lustig, mittlerweile, muss das auf YouTube oder auf Twitch sagen,
schon kommen alle um die Ecke, war sogar gar nicht so uninteressant,
muss ich, werde ich, werde ich darauf antworten, habe ich eben gerade erst gesehen,
so, auf jetzt, mach mal hier eine Update, ich muss das Ding noch Rebooten gleich und dann können
wir anfangen, ja, während der Update, ich habe jetzt mein Passwort eingegeben, also die anderen
Issues noch mal kurz gezeigt, also das erste ist, das erste ist das mit den, mit den Containern,
das ist glaube ich relativ einfach zu fixen, ich glaube, das machen wir auch als erstes, ich muss
mein Home Assistant zum Testen updaten, hier, unbedingt Home Assistant updaten, sonst können
wir es gar nicht ausprobieren, klar, so, das nächste ist, das nächste, das nächste Issue,
was es gibt, ist Login, Login Auth Error, der kann sich nicht einloggen und zwar,
ich habe da auch schon eine Vermutung, warum, der hat ein Auto, was ich so noch nie gesehen
habe, in Kombination, es hatte bisher auch noch keine Ausbreit, der hat nämlich einen Dodge,
das ist irgendwie so ein Ami Ding, ich wusste bis zu dem Zeitpunkt, als ich dieses Endon
programmiert habe, gar nicht, dass es Dodge überhaupt gibt, genauso wie, hier ist das andere
Ding, Sekunde, Ram, habe ich auch noch nie gehört, Leute, ich meine, ernsthafte Frage an euch,
wusste ihr, dass es diese beiden Auto Hersteller gibt, also ich habe weder von Dodge noch von Ram
was gehört, das sind wohl Trucks, bei den Amis scheint mir das sehr, echt, kennt ihr das, ich
habe das noch nie gehört, also es ist, irgendeine Ami Geschichte, Trucks, die bauen irgendwie so,
so, also keine richtig großen LKWs, sondern halt so, Ami Trucks, nein, Ram ist kein Dodge,
ne, ne, das sind unterschiedliche Seiten, zumindest intern, wie die Firma aufgebaut ist,
letztendlich ist es ja alles Fiat Chrysler und hast du nicht gesehen, Ruin Talmo, danke schön
für den Sub, so, und, ja, also, wie gesagt, habe ich ja nie gehört, ja, vielleicht bin ich
von Mond, keine Ahnung, ich kannte das beides nicht, Petter Pickup, ja, so war es in der Richter,
so, und die haben das Problem, die können sich nicht einloggen, ganz ehrlich, ich glaube,
es gibt einfach schlicht und ergreifend gar keine Konfig dafür aktuell, dass Dodge aus NA funktioniert,
das probieren wir auch gleich aus, müssen wir uns einen Fake Account machen auf connect-dodge.com,
gibt es auch nur, gibt es auch nur, Kokona Land, Wolle, danke schön für den Sub, dann gibt es
auch nur USA oder Kanada, dann müssen wir uns gleich einen Fake Account machen, das ausprobieren,
ich glaube, das stimmt, ich vermute, das ist relativ einfach zu fixen, wir müssen gucken,
welche Urls das verwendet, das hinterlegen und dann GG Eats, dann sollte Dodge eigentlich
funktionieren, weil prinzipiell verwenden die alle die gleiche API, die Settings sind
bloß unterschiedlich, die sind unterschiedlich nach Region und die sind unterschiedlich nach
Vendor, also sprich, welches Auto du hast, welcher Hersteller und welche Region, ist das immer ein
bisschen unterschiedlich, die verwenden dann beispielsweise Amazon EU West als Endpunkt
oder Amazon US East als Endpunkt, je nachdem wo du bist, das müssen wir einfach mal ausprobieren,
deswegen müssen wir uns auch einen Ami Dodge Account machen, also das werden wir fixen,
der hat wohl noch ein anderes Problem, dass sein Auto nicht richtig funktioniert in der
Webseite, aber gut, das hat ja erstmal mit dem Login nichts zu tun, so und dann haben wir das
eigentliche, was wahrscheinlich ein bisschen komplizierter ist, der C-Graf, der hat ein Jeep,
hast du nie Fast und Furious geguckt, doch, den ersten Teil habe ich geguckt und den fand
ich ultra dämlich und hat mir nie wieder was anderes davon angeguckt, gab es da auch schon
Dodge und Ram Trucks, ist aber schon, das ist wahrscheinlich um 15 Uhr her oder so wo ich den
gesehen habe, weiß gar nicht, wann der erste rausgekommen ist, also und das hier ist das
eigentliche Problem, wo ich noch nicht genau weiß woran es liegt, also der Kerl hier hat anscheinend
einen Jeep, aha, keine Ahnung, so genau kann ich mich da nicht mehr dran erinnern, der hat einen Jeep und der hat
Probleme beim Abrufen seiner Auto Infos und das, obwohl das Login offensichtlich funktioniert hat,
weil hätte das Login, er ist ja auch schlau gewesen, er hat gleich mal Dibaklog hier dabei
gepostet und Dibaklog ohne irgendwelche IDs, ja das ist gut, also das Login funktioniert,
sonst hätte es hier keinen Token gegeben und es war vorher schon kaputt gegangen, aber trotzdem
hat er irgendwelche Probleme seine Auto Infos abzurufen, so und der hat einen Jeep, der hat
einen Jeep Grand Cherokee, falls man das so ausspricht, 4xXD und er kriegt irgendwelche
Probleme, das versuchen wir auch gleich mal nachzustellen, ich weiß, dass das Addon prinzipiell
in Amerika und mit Jeeps funktioniert, weil es gab hier letztens ein Issue von einem,
der hat einen Jeep Cladiator aus Brasilien und er konnte sich gar nicht richtig einloggen,
ja und da habe ich geguckt, welche Region und was auch immer und dann habe ich das gefixt und dann
hat es funktioniert, also ich weiß nicht genau, was das Ding hier für Schwärzen hat bei ihm,
vielleicht ist er auch gebannt oder so, kann ja auch sein, das heißt, wir werden hier mal ein
bisschen Dibak einbauen, so nach dem Motto, warum geht es eigentlich kaputt, ja genau,
das werden wir machen, gucken wir uns gleich an, vorher muss ich wahrscheinlich einmal neustellen,
also um diese drei Issues kümmern wir uns heute, wir können sogar richtig Hyper Agile sein und
das ganze mal selbst zu, ach ich bin gar nicht eingeloggt, okay Sekunde Leute, ich bin mir
nicht sicher, ob ich zwei Fakta Authentifizierung habe, don't save, E-Mail liegt, das ist die E-Mail,
wo man auch spenden kann, die ist public, ist nichts, nichts Geheimes, okay, zeig mal hier
zwei Fakta Authentifizierung, Alter, das ist meine Nachricht auf dem Handy weg, okay nice,
Tja haben Leute schon gemacht, willst du machen, aber wie gesagt die E-Mail ist eh public,
so, also, weiter geht's, exellent, sind wir eingeloggt auf GitHub, wir können es jetzt
super agile machen und zwar wir sind heute super agil, hab ich ja gesagt, wir machen das jetzt auf
und weisen uns das erst mal selbst zu, weil Pog, zeig mal her, wie sieht es jetzt aus,
als Bug getagged, Enhancement getagged, alles gut, was hat der noch geschrieben,
was hat er denn noch geschrieben, das sind mittlerweile acht,
so, was haben denn, ich muss mal kurz gucken, was hat der noch geschrieben, also bla bla bla bla
bla bla, wer ist denn Lotza Matron, was hat er denn noch geschrieben, also ich hab eine Sache
festgestellt, die Leute lesen die ReadMe immer nicht richtig, wer hätte das gedacht, Leute,
hättet ihr das vermutet, hätte keiner drauf kommen können, dass die Leute die ReadMe nicht
richtig lesen, und zwar, ich hab extra in die ReadMe geschrieben, dass prerequisites, man muss
gucken, dass ein Auto auf einem dieser Seiten funktioniert, das machen die meisten aber nicht,
das hier ist ein absolut legit Issue, bei ihm bin ich mir halt hier nicht sicher, ob er das gemacht
hat, weil es gibt mehrere Uconnect Seiten, und wichtig ist, dass es auf diesen Uconnect Seiten
funktioniert, es gibt noch eine andere Uconnect Seite, nämlich hier mopa.com, achso, mein Firefox
ist kaputt, weil, ja okay, ich muss mal rebooten, muss rebooten, weil kernel update und alles, es
sind zu wenige Emojis, ja das ist, machen ein Pullrequest, easy, machen ein Pullrequest, wir
machen mehr Emoji, Emoji fire ReadMe, blazingly fast, super easy, was schreibt man da sonst noch
so rein, written in Rust, Leute, soll ich einfach in meine addon ReadMe reinschreiben, written in
Rust, obwohl es nicht in Rust geschrieben ist, ich meine, das ist aber eigentlich egal, das guckt sich
ja eh keiner so richtig, wirklich an, ich könnte einfach reinschreiben, blazingly fast, written in
Rust, weil, wenn irgendjemand rausbekommt, dass es nicht written in Rust ist, was soll schon passieren,
Fake Rust, Memory Save, oh ja, das ist natürlich bei einem Addon, was im Prinzip 95% Webrequest
macht, äußerst wichtig, dass das super Memo, weil was soll da groß passieren, also mit der eingebauten
HTTP Library wohlgemerkt, Memory Save, okay, blazingly fast, Memory Save, also ich bin ja bisher so
blöd gewesen, ich bin ja bisher so blöd gewesen und habe tatsächlich sinnvolle Features dahin
geschrieben, ja, zum Beispiel, dass du verschiedene Autos verwenden kannst, auf dem kleinen Account, dass du
Location Tracking kannst und sowas, das ist, eigentlich ist es total irrelevant, da muss
blazingly fast, written in Rust stehen, aber ihr habt schon recht, da sind schon wenig Emojis,
oder, müssten definitiv mehr Emojis, Location Tracking, könnt man zum Beispiel eine Map dahinter
machen, hier könnte man eine App dahinter machen, ein Smartphone dahinter, Remote Commands, könnte
man irgendwie ein Wi-Fi Symbol oder sowas dahinter machen, was auch immer, so haben wir jetzt alles
geupdatet, ist das jetzt geschafft, ja, easy, gut, dann machen wir vielleicht noch ein Kernel Update,
falls es noch, falls es einen neueren gibt, ich habe immer noch den LTS Kernel, wie jetzt,
outdated, overrated, debated Kernel, warum bin ich immer noch ein 515 Mann, ja gut, warum auch nicht,
es ist ja nicht, dass es nicht einen großartigen Unterschied macht, egal, wir rebooten jetzt mal
schnell und dann geht's los, multiple cast 2K, Leute, ich sehe schon, ihr wisst Bescheid,
ihr solltet, ihr solltet mir mal ein paar Emoji, Emoji Fight Read Me Pull Requests stellen,
dann machen wir das, hast du dieses Wochenende schon Battlefield 2042 gespielt, oh was, aktuell
ist free weekend, wirklich, das muss ich mal ausprobieren, Leute, free weekend, Loops, Beschen,
Wo stehen die Termine Xbox ach hier bis zum vierten Dezember bis zum fünften Dezember
ok also sprich bis Montagabend ja das muss man auf jeden Fall ausprobieren heute heute
heute heute Mittag nicht im Stream jetzt machen wir erstmal das vielleicht machen wir heute Abend
aber noch eine Runde Battlefield dann. Ist das jetzt irgendwie schlecht oder so dass ich
connected bin to Wired Connection 1? Ich hab diese Message noch nie gesehen. Ist das jetzt was Gutes
oder soll ich mir da jetzt Gedanken machen? Ja don't show again. Welche Connection soll
er bitteschön auch sonst verwenden? Es gibt doch nur Wired Connection 1. Aber war dir das Chat?
Wer von euch war das wieder? Wem seine Connection verwende ich jetzt? Über welches VPN werde ich
gerade weitergeleitet? Biginjp der war es. Ja ich sehe es im Chat. Leaked. Ok Firefox. Restore
Session. Alles klar so können wir anfangen. Gut jetzt muss ich mal kurz was überlegen warum
habe ich denn eigentlich so viel Speicherplatz hier was ist denn das? Also so wenig so wenig
Speicherplatz. Du bist im Mainframe. Ja das ist gut dann kannst du dann nicht bei mir sein
weil ich habe kein Mainframe. Zumindest noch nicht. Konnte man hier nicht sagen. Settings
und dann löschen der alten Version irgendwie. Leftover. Clear Download Cache. Jawoll. Erstmal
den ganzen. Ja ja. Erstmal den ganzen Müll löschen. Haben wir da ein bisschen Platz
und jetzt gucken wir mal Leute ncdu. Bestes bestes Tool. Unter Linux wenn ihr raus bekommen
wollt wo ist Speicherplatz. Wo wird Speicherplatz verbraucht. Ncdu. Dauert jetzt ein bisschen
weil ich hier 30 Milliarden mini kleine Dateien am Start habe. Aber dann sieht man wo viel
Speicherplatz verbraucht wird. Ncdu. Was schon traurig das Battlefield 2042 an Free Weekend
braucht um die Spielerzahl von Battlefield 1 zu erreichen. Ja gut. Battlefield 1 ist ja auch
irgendwie ein halbwegs rundes Ding. Vor allem sieht das viel viel besser aus als 2042. Die
Maps haben auch mehr Details. Letztens habe ich doch ein Video darüber gemacht dass die neue Map
kaum Details hat. Das ist halt einfach nur ein bisschen Wiese ist und ja leere Häuser und dann
kam dann wieder so ein wichtig Tour in den Kommentaren an. Das sind ja Leute die triggern mich
immer. Die dann in den Kommentaren schreiben so so die neue Map hat etwa keine Details. Dann hast
du dir die neue Map wohl noch nicht genau angeguckt. Doch. Natürlich habe ich mir die
angeguckt und ich habe keine wirklich Details gesehen. Ich meine Kisten. Kisten und Container
in Battlefield als Details. Dann hat das Spiel auf jeden Fall sehr viele Details. Alles andere
nicht so wirklich. So das können wir löschen. Irgendwelche Grammier weiß ich nicht was das ist.
Guck mal wir haben Cash. Ganz viel Cash. Package. Package Cash. Local. Share. JetBrains. Trash.
Okay. Trash. Empty. Yes. Cannot remove. DNS Stels. Warum nicht? Warum kann er DNS Stels nicht
remove? Wahrscheinlich weil es falsche Berechtigungen sind. Aber wir können mal Pack. Cash. Ein paar
Sachen löschen wieder. Okay. Zehn Gigabyte wieder freigegeben. Das sollte passen. Ja. Nice.
GG Eats. Gut. Dann starten wir das mal und dann gucken wir uns das an. Wir fangen an mit dem
Container Feature würde ich sagen. Das sollte am einfachsten zu machen sein. 4Cham. Geh
nochmal weg. 4Cham. Das ist richtig. Das brauchen wir. Ich muss jetzt nur mal die letzte Version
pullen. Gitstatus. Was haben wir denn hier alles? Bloop.txt. Okay das lösche ich mal. Da steht
nämlich glaube ich mal ein Passwort vom letzten Mal noch drin. Das wollen wir nicht mehr. Das
wollen wir schon mal gar nicht einchecken. Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher was wir hier gemacht haben,
aber ganz im Ernst. Ich glaube das ist nichts was ich noch brauche. Für den Fall der Fälle
stashen wir das mal. Git pull Origin. Origin Master. Leute mir fällt gerade auf. Mein
Brian Scheiß ja noch Master. Lasst es mal bitte nicht Twitter mitkriegen Leute. Was meint ihr was
dann los ist? Das Patriarchat greift wieder um sich hier. Git pull Origin Masters sind für aktuell.
Zeit mal her. Loc region bug. Das ist glaube ich wirklich hier passt. Das letzte was ich commit.
13 Tage ist es schon wieder her, dass ich hier was drin gemacht habe. Okay da wird es mal wirklich
Zeit da jetzt ein paar Sachen zu fixen. Yo. Was habe ich hier zuletzt gemacht? Ich weiß es nicht
mehr. Gucken wir mal kurz. Okay das ist einfacher fix gewesen. Region fix. Brand region found car.
Irgendwelche Zeilenumbrüche, Versionsnummer. Guckt mal Leute ich habe. Ach nee das ist der
Chip der fix für Jeep. Der fix für Jeep war das. Okay okay okay. Ja kriegen wir schon wieder hin.
Also Git checkout machen wir mal einen eigenen Branch auf und zwar wir machen das jetzt mal ganz
furchtbar korrekt ja. Wir machen jetzt einen eigenen Branch auf. Feature Standalone Docker.
Achso Checkout minus B. So ordentlich wäre ich normalerweise jetzt nicht, aber sind wir mal.
Sind wir mal ganz furchtbar ordentlich. Gut wir machen jetzt wir kümmern uns jetzt um diesen,
um dieses Issue hier. Das sollte relativ easy machbar sein. Issue number ja. Ja okay komm,
weil ihr es seid, weil ihr es seid. Also das da brauchen wir jetzt. 22. Komm machen wir auch
noch einen. Git Branch minus M. So wie heißt das Ding jetzt? Feature Standalone Docker. Jetzt
dürft ihr euch aussuchen. Wie soll ich es nennen? So? Oder so? Oder was wollt ihr haben?
22 minus. Minus mache ich nicht gerne in Git Branches. Wisst ihr warum? Ist eine Eigenheit
von uns auf der Arbeit und zwar wir verwenden zum größten Teil Puppet als Config Management
System und Puppet mag Minus und Slashes überhaupt gar nicht.
In Environment Namen. Deswegen mache ich immer keine Minus. Okay weil ihr es seid wir machen 22
Minus Standalone Docker. Okay alles klar. Gut jetzt haben wir den eigenen Branch. Jetzt können
wir uns das Ganze mal angucken. Das sollte tatsächlich sich relativ einfach fixen lassen. Also nur mal
zur Erklärung was der was der hier was der hier machen will. Es schadet ja immer nicht sich das
mal durchzulesen was die Leute vorhaben aber ich habe es mir schon durchgelöst weil ich habe schon
darauf geantwortet und zwar der betreibt Home Assistant Standalone also spricht er an ein
eigenes Docker Compose File. Dort hat es einen Container mit Home Assistant drin aber er möchte
meinen Addon verwenden und mein Addon ist ein Home Assistant Addon das setzt normalerweise voraus
dass man das gesamte Home Assistant Paket verwendet wo der Addon Manager dabei ist. Wenn man es
Standalone selbst betreibt in einem Container dann ist dort kein Addon Manager dabei weil was
soll der Addon Manager managen? Da kann er schlecht seine selbstgemanagten Docker Container auch
managen. Das funktioniert ja nicht. Das heißt er möchte jetzt quasi sein Docker Compose File
irgendwie ergänzen um einen Fiat Champ Container und das funktioniert aktuell nicht zumindest nicht
so ohne weiteres weil wenn man hier mal in der Startscript rein guckt vom Container dann werden
hier ganz dann werden hier aus der Addon Config was man normalerweise über das Web Interface ich
muss mein Home Assistant updaten. Welche IP hatten das Ding? 132 ok wenn ich das nämlich nicht
update. Was hab ichs? Warte mal. Ok sehr schön. Mein Home Assistant der ist ja hier nur zum
Testen da nicht wundern dass da nichts drinne steht weil das ist einfach nur einfach nur da um
da zu sein dass ich so Sachen hier ausprobieren kann. Ich mach mal kurz ein Update. Home Assistant
Update Update Update Update alles klar installieren. So und während der installiert erzähle ich jetzt
mal weiter. Next Cloud vs. On Cloud vs. C File Umfrage vorschlagen. Ja können wir machen.
Also ich persönlich mag Next Cloud und On Cloud gar nicht. Ich hab Not getrunken noch eine Next
Cloud in Betrieb aber einfach nur weil ich bisher zu faul war das abzuschalten. Also ich mags nicht
sondern nicht C File hab ich nie großartig ausprobiert. Aber wir können eine Umfrage machen. Ich mach
mal schnell eine. Es ist übrigens auch gut dass du drei Sachen gefragt hast weil der Chat hat
das neueste Hobby bei Umfragen was sie nicht interessiert einfach das immer 50 50 ausgehen
lassen. Das geht ja hier nicht. Es geht vielleicht 33 33 33 oder so aber das das dann genau treffen
ist schwierig. So ihr könnt abstimmen. Interessiert mich tatsächlich mal was da rauskommt. Tja wir
machen. Ich füge noch. Ja ich mach noch eine vierte. Ich mach noch eine vierte Option rein.
Was anderes. Slash braucht man nicht. Alles klar. Dauer eine Minute. Bäm dann zeigt mal her. Ich bin
immer gespannt. Also wie gesagt ich bin kein großer Fan von Next Cloud und On Cloud. C File hab ich
noch nie ausprobiert. Also ich tendiere aktuell tatsächlich zu einem anderen Produkt und zwar
für das was man machen will was passendes. Ja wenn man eigentlich nur Kaldorf Kalender will dann
braucht man kein Next Cloud sondern kann beispielsweise irgendeinen Kaldorf Server verwenden. Für Datalsync
gibt es auch was anderes. Aber ich glaube ansonsten ist das verbreitetste wahrscheinlich aktuell
Next Cloud. Ja. Alle schrecklich Next Cloud am wenigsten. Okay. Ja kann ich. Okay damit kann ich
noch leben. Moin du hast die Frage bestimmt schon ein paar mal beantwortet aber wie lief dein
Vorstellungsgespräch. Hast du das Video gesehen von gestern. Da habe ich mich doch darüber ausgelassen.
15 Minuten. Geht das auf mobile. Das ist eine gute Frage. Ich habe keine Ahnung ob auf mobile
Twitch umfragen gehen. Hast du. Ach du meinst die andere. Da sage ich nichts zu weil das noch
nicht so wirklich ganz spruchreif ist was da rausgekommen ist. Außerdem für mehr Content.
Wenn ich jetzt alles liege kann ich da kein Video mehr drüber machen. Okay also Next Cloud
gefolgt von sie weil. Und viele sagen braucht man nicht oder wollen was anderes was anderes
verwenden. Alles klar. Heute Weihnachtsfeier auf sowas. Ja ich bin unglaublicher Fan von
Weihnachtsfeiern Sommerfesten und und sonstigen Sachen. Generell nach der Arbeitszeit noch auf
der Arbeit rumhängen kann ich mir nichts besseres vorstellen. Nächstes Video
bald wirklich arbeitslos. Kann sein. Aber wisst ihr was das gute ist. Ich habe im Video schon
gesagt was mich auch äußerst beruhigt. Ich bin nicht so wirklich ich bin eigentlich nie
so wirklich arbeitslos. Ich mache halt mehrere Sachen. Hat er jetzt geupdatet hier. Nochmal
updaten. Okay installieren. Was. Fehler beim Aufruf. Blockt. Warum. Wo ist das. Wo ist das
Problem. Supervisor needs to be updated first. Okay. Funktioniert ja wieder erstklassig hier.
Was Pull Request ist da. Und ihr habt jetzt wirklich meine Web meine meine Ritme Emoji
Feiert. Nö stimmt überhaupt nicht. Okay Operating System vielleicht vorher installieren.
Ach so ich war in den Issues. Ups. Du hast recht. Pull Request ist da. Edit Emoji. Okay zeigt
mal her. Files changed. Erstmal hat er ordentliche Commit Message gemacht. Ja sehr gute Commit
Message. Edit Emojis POG. Genauso stelle ich mir eine gute. Nein du kannst doch nicht
written in Rust dahinter schreiben. Das Ding ist nicht. Das war ein Witz. Das Ding ist
nicht in Rust geritten. Du musst da schon was ordentliches dahinter schreiben. Mach
den Rust weg man. Das kannst du nicht hinschreiben. Okay das hier finde ich gut. Car or Truck.
Ist das ein Bug. Okay nein. Oh guck mal hier jetzt wird es aber advanced. Battery Level
Tire Pressure. Tire Pressure. Was heißt das auf Deutsch. Zähler Kilometer Zähler. Multiple.
Was hast du schön gemacht mit den drei farbigen Autos. Das finde ich gut. Location Tracking
Homework. Schlepp. Okay das hast du schön Emojified. Nicht Tacho. Kilometer Zähler.
Ja sehr gut. Aber written in Rust. Refresh. Da ist es weg. Okay ich überlege mir das
nachher ob ich das haben will. Wir müssen nämlich nachher noch was hinzufügen in die
Readme. Nämlich wie man das mit den Docker Containern macht. So wie sieht es denn jetzt
hier mit dem Home Assistant Update aus. Hat er es heute noch mal geschafft. Hey easy jetzt
darf ich Home Assistant Core auch updaten. Okay sehr schön. Du kannst jetzt in dein Lebenslauf
schreiben ja Open Source Contributor. Ich mein komm das Projekt hat auch mittlerweile
an die 30 Sterne. Ich glaube 29 oder so. Ja 29 Sterne. Ab wann ist man ein großes Projekt
auf GitHub. Ich mein laut GitHub ist man glaube ich ab 12 Sternen. GitHub ist glaube ich ab
12 Sternen ist das ein großes Projekt oder wie auch immer sie das nennen. Weil man kann
auf GitHub ja auch mittlerweile Achievements anlocken. Und es gibt das Achievement glaube
ich für ein Multistar was auch immer. Projekt gibt es glaube ich ab 12. Gibt es glaube ich ab 12 Sternen.
Home Assistant wurde vollständig gestartet. Okay sehr nice. Der 4er Champ kann geupdatet
werden. Okay das schauen wir uns auch mal kurz an. Hier steht doch bestimmt nur Mülltrennen
oder Configuration. Cackleatexample.com. Ja das funktioniert ganz bestimmt so nicht.
Aber wir können es aktualisieren. Das ist auf jeden Fall schon mal nicht verkehrt. Dann sind
wir auf dem aktuellen Stand. Gut weil dann kümmern uns kümmern uns wir mal um die ganze
Docker-Geschichte hier. So. Containerized Home Assistant. Alles klar. Oh. Unknown Error.
C Supervisor. Wieso hat das doch funktioniert? Alter diese Fehlermeldung immer. Unknown Error.
Und jetzt Update hat funktioniert. Nevermind. Europe. Speichern. Alright. Gut. Beim Booten
starten. Nein nein nein nein nein nein nein nein. Beim Booten wird hier nichts gestartet.
Sogar Poggers ReadMe am Start. Seht ihr das? Massive ReadMe. Hi IQ ReadMe. Moin Chainlaw.
Gut. Also wie ich mir das vorgestellt habe folgendermaßen. Also der hier hat seine eigenen
Docker Compose File mit Home Assistant drin und der will das Addon betreiben. Was aktuell
nicht geht. Weil das Addon über den Addon Manager von Home Assistant installiert werden
muss. Das was ihr gerade hier gesehen habt. Also das da. Addon. Addon Store. Guckt hier.
Das ist der Addon Manager für Home Assistant. Und den hat er hier nicht. Weil er Home Assistant
eben in dem eigenen Docker Container ohne Addon Manager und alles betreibt. Was wir
machen können ist, was ich mir überlegt habe. Wir könnten das Startscript anpassen, dass
man es auch Standalone betreiben kann. Jetzt müssen wir jetzt mal ausbringen, ob das überhaupt
ordentlich funktioniert. Von der Idee her sollte das relativ einfach sein. Leute im Forum habe
ich das schon geschrieben. So nach dem Motto, das ist eigentlich gar nicht richtig zu verwenden.
Ich glaube aber, es ist relativ easy das anzupassen. Und zwar guckt euch mal dieses Startscript
an. So. In dem Startscript. Ach so. Das hier oben funktioniert das schon gar nicht mal
richtig. So bevor wir irgendwas machen, bevor wir irgendwas machen, müssen wir die Versionsnummer
erstmal erhöhen. Config. By the way. Hier Wim Magic Leute. Kennt ihr das? Steuerung X und
Steuerung A. Kann Wim sogar zählen. Wo war man? Ich glaube 303. Tauschen mit den Weihnachts.
Weihnachts E-Modes. Ja, mache ich. Mache ich. Wird mal Zeit. Mache ich. Da muss ich. Wo haben
wir denn Keg? Ah hier Keg W. Wo sieht man das denn jetzt überhaupt? Wo sieht man meine
Channel E-Modes? E-Modes? Personal E-Modes? Wo sehe ich denn Barbetta Twitch TV überhaupt?
Wo haben wir denn überhaupt Keg W her? Keg W. Was ist denn jetzt schon wieder? Ach FFZ
ist das. Okay. FFZ. Oh nee. Da muss ich mich jetzt neu anmelden bei Twitch. Vergiss es.
Kann ich jetzt nicht machen. Das dauert mir doch zu lang. Ja. Nee. Da müsste jetzt Passwort
und so alles raussuchen. Nee, das mache ich dann. Warte mal. Das kann ich mir jetzt nicht geben. Also
wir haben jetzt die Versionsnummer angepasst. Das ist erst mal das Wichtigste. Wenn wir die
Versionsnummer nicht anpassen, dann funktioniert gar nichts. Also Leute, ich habe jetzt irgendwie
ein bisschen. Ich bin jetzt ein bisschen planlos, wie wir das am besten machen. Normalerweise hätte
ich gesagt, okay, wenn man dieses Standalone betreiben möchte, dann kann man selbstverständlich
diese ganze Konfig-Geschichte hier nicht benutzen. Wie wird man so ein krasser Hacker, wo man lernt,
aus Wim rauszukommen? Udemy Kurs buchen. Haben die überhaupt einen Wim Kurs? Wahrscheinlich.
Na gut, nachdem es das gleiche Image ist, müsste das funktionieren. Also theoretisch,
theoretisch könnte man einfach sowas hier machen. Standalone. Zum Beispiel ja. Standalone. Nee,
das müssen wir doch jetzt hier checken. Standalone. Wie testet man den Bash-Geschein, ob eine
Variable gesetzt ist? Variable ist set. How to check if variable is set in Bash. Okay,
Stack Overflow. Usually this is the right. Aha, Minus Z. Oh, oh, das ist high IQ. Was ist denn das?
What? Okay, was, was, was genau macht das? Funktioniert den ZSH schon mal, das ist auch gut.
Keck. Okay, das muss in Bash laufen, sonst. Nee, in Bash funktioniert das auch nicht.
Ah nee, dann habe ich das falsch gelesen. Okay, war gleich eins.
Ah nee, Moment, war muss ich groß schreiben. Ah, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay. Verstehe. Boah,
das ist auch schon geil. Warum überhaupt zu komplizieren? Jetzt mal blöde Frage. Warum
überhaupt zu kompliziert? Mein Z, Z ist doch, String is not empty, oder? Nee, String is,
String is zero. Warum überhaupt plus X? Wenn ich eine Variable versuche einzulesen,
die es nicht gibt, dann ist es doch auch leer. Warum muss man es dann so kompliziert machen?
Also, kann ich nicht einfach sagen, hier minus Z und dann irgendwie sowas hier. Stand alone.
V, dann L. Ich hoffe, ich hoffe, das funktioniert überhaupt so. So Bash aus dem Kopf ist immer
so eine Sache. Guck mal hier, Vim Magic Leute, hier. I, Leerzeichen, Leerzeichen, bam. Okay,
ich teste, ich teste das mal kurz, ob das funktioniert, was ich da oben geschrieben
habe. If test stand alone, then Echo Cackle. B, Cackle, okay. Sollte eigentlich nicht funktionieren,
weil stand alone ist leer. Aber Moment, Z, Z ist ercheckt, ob zero ist. Ich muss N machen.
Ist zero, achso, nee, ich muss N machen, is non zero, is non zero. Okay, ja, ja, jetzt
passt es. So, okay, gut. Also, geht nicht. Und jetzt sagen wir mal hier, stand alone gleich
L, gleich Lul V. Ja, jetzt gehts. Ja, ja, okay, alles klar. Dir fehlen die Dings, nee,
die fehlen nicht, test es das gleiche. Guck mal, pass mal auf, mind blown Leute. Wisst
ihr, dass das funktioniert? Wie, das geht nicht mehr? Okay, das vielleicht nur in Bash.
Hä, früher konnte man mann-eckige Klammer aufmachen und man kam dann im Ende bei mann-page
für test raus. Aber anscheinend ist das nicht mehr so, gut.
Äh, ah, da oben, ich hab's ja schon offen. Also, if, so, wenn, minus N, also, wenn es,
es muss es nämlich da doch rein, wenn es nicht stand alone ist, was sagt denn eigentlich
Stack Overflow dazu, dass das so kompliziert gemacht ist? Okay, das ist der Wrong Way,
den ich mache. Warum ist das, warum ist das wrong? Warum ist das wrong? Ja, okay, versteh
ich, versteh ich, aber ist mir in dem Fall scheißegal, ehrlich gesagt. Wenn da nicht
True drinne steht oder irgendwas, dann ist, ja. Okay, das ist aber wirklich clever, ja.
Jetzt versteh ich auch, jetzt versteh ich auch, warum das Plus X hinten dran hat. Jetzt
leuchte das ein, I can't, genau. Jetzt versteh ich das. Okay, auf die Idee bin ich auch schon
gekommen, Stack Overflow. Ah gut, das ist okay so. So, äh, test stand alone und ansonsten
übrigens das else können wir uns schenken, der muss ja eh alles selbst exportieren. Ich
glaube, das ist alles, was wir brauchen, um das zu fixen, was er haben will. If Tests,
also wenn stand alone nicht leer ist, Moment, ne, wenn stand alone leer ist oder not leer,
oh Leute, mein Güte, wie war das jetzt? Null, ne? Ja, ist zero, also sprich, okay, wenn
es nicht, wenn es nicht belegt ist, alles richtig so, dann führt er den Kram aus wie
bisher und ansonsten macht er nichts, was okay ist, weil die Leute müssen dann einfach die
Variablen selbst setzen. Ich glaube, das ist tatsächlich den einzigen Fix, den wir brauchen
dafür. Git commit minus A minus M, wie war das auf GitHub? Also man kann in GitHub sowas
machen, aber ich glaube, man kann auch einfach das da machen, ja? Ich glaube, das geht auch.
Ja? Git push, achso, mir fällt gerade ein, Feature Branch ist ja schön und gut, aber
ich habe eine Action, die den neuen Container baut und die Containerbau Action geht bloß,
wenn ein Release Branch gepusht wird, glaube ich. Ah, nur Release oder Fix, okay Leute,
wir verabschieden uns von unserem schönen Feature Branch, das Ding wird jetzt renamed
zu Fix, aus ist, nicht Feature 22 Standalone Docker, das heißt einfach nur Fix, beste
unklarer Name überhaupt, Git push Origin, Git push Origin Fix, er würde mir jetzt wahrscheinlich
sagen, den Branch gibt es schon, deswegen machen wir jetzt mal Delete und jetzt pushen
wir den neu. Gut, alles klar und er sollte jetzt normalerweise unter Actions, ja, huge
Naming, ja, er sollte jetzt eigentlich ein neues Container Image bauen mit diesem Versionstack,
er sollte neues Image bauen für Raspberry Pi und für Desktop. What? Was willst du
von mir? Warning. Package has resource. Alter. Ach, Warnings. Wer braucht schon Warnings?
Safe Command is deprecated. Was zum Teufel will das von mir? Wir ignorieren die Warnings,
ja, finde ich auch sinniger. Wer braucht Warnings? Macht er hier? Publish, ID, okay, nice. So,
jetzt ist das neue Image gepusht und wenn ich das jetzt richtig sehe, können wir das
sogar ausprobieren, ob das neue Image jetzt funktioniert und zwar. Wir gehen mal auf Packages,
AMD 64, getaggt vor einer Minute und kopieren uns das hier mal. Dann jetzt Docker Run, probieren
das mal aus. Wie war das? Docker Run? Minus Minus M, Minus ID. Aber ich kann mir das immer
nicht merken. Und das kommt weg. Name. Package. Ah, nee, dann ist es einfach nur Minus ID.
Okay, gut. Das Image ist schon mal da. Okay, Standalone, Unbound Variable. Wie jetzt?
Was will der, was will der mir sagen? Unbound Variable? Moment, ist der so pingelig und
sagt, weil die nicht, äh, muss ich das vielleicht doch so machen? Muss ich das vielleicht doch
so machen, wie das Stack Overflow tut, macht? Aus irgendwelchen Gründen? Wir können das
machen wie die coolen Leute von Stack Overflow. Also quasi so. Komm, wir machen es dann.
Wir copypasten es einfach. Wir sind gute Entwickler. Wir copypasten es einfach von Stack Overflow
und Gutes. Wobei das so rum falsch ist, oder? Das ist doch so rum falsch. Wir wollen es,
wir wollen das nicht ausführen, wenn es gesetzt ist. Geht es, geht es denn jetzt auch umgedreht,
muss ich sagen, wenn nicht gesetzt, können wir das auch umdrehen. Ich meine, wir können
es noch besser, noch besser. Wir lassen das so, wie es ist. Wir lassen das so, wie es
ist. Machen denn Else? Und hier sagen wir einfach Echo Running in Standalone Mode. Vielleicht
gar nicht so schlecht, dass man es auch, dass ich es auch unterscheiden kann beim Starten,
was passiert. Ok. Gucken wir, ob das jetzt funktioniert. Machen denn Ausrufezeichen
davor? Was? Vor was? Vor was soll ich ein Ausrufezeichen machen? Ach so, du meinst Inverten.
Ja, ja, das kenne ich. Du meinst hier Invert. Ja, ja, das ist das richtig. Das kenne ich.
Aber so rum ist eigentlich sogar noch besser. Dann da sehen wir nämlich auch, dass es funktioniert.
Ok, also Status. Wir hängen das jetzt einfach hinten dran. Am Ende. Push. Und jetzt ganz
böse Leute. Force. In dem Fall ist es kein Problem. Ich bin der Einzige, der daran arbeitet.
So, Actions. Dann mach mal. Ach so, jetzt haben wir den gleichen Tag wie vorher. Checkt
das Docker überhaupt, wenn es das gleiche Tag hat, aber sich das geändert hat? Was dahinter
steht? Na gut, warten wir mal ab. Building Release. Residenz Sleeper Time. Jetzt läuft
das nur, wenn Standalone gesetzt ist. Ups. Ja, schauen wir mal. Wir werden es ja auf jeden
Fall. Wir werden es ja auf jeden Fall sehen. Haben wir es? Finished. Wie kann ich jetzt
Docker sagen, dass er das Refetchen soll? Docker? Kann man Docker Pull oder so? Ah ja,
ok. Jetzt hat er es gecheckt. Running in Standalone. Ok, funktioniert. Funktioniert. Alles gut.
Nur mit dem Unterschied, dass ich blöd das falsch rumgeschrieben habe, weil das ist
aber auch ein Bash aller Brainfuck man. Hier. Wenn Standalone gesetzt ist, dann führt er
das hier aus. Es ist ja falsch rum. Ich habe das falsch rum gemacht. Oder einfach ein Ausrufezeichen
davor. Aber so ist auch ok. Gut. So, das müsste jetzt funktionieren. Push. Ach so, jaja. Gut,
da hätten wir nämlich das schon mal gefixt. Sehen wir gleich, ob es funktioniert. Wir
können das ja mal ausprobieren. Wenn ich das ausführe. Running in Standalone Mode.
So, dann funktioniert das natürlich nicht, weil dieser ganze Krämpel nicht gesetzt ist.
Das bedeutet, damit das funktioniert, müssen die Leute jetzt allen Ernstes sowas hier
machen. Wie war das Variablen setzen? Minus E. Und dann zum Beispiel sowas wie Fiat User.
Boah, das ist ja eklig. Also, Leute müssen dann sowas hier exportieren zum Beispiel.
Gut, ich meine, ich recommende das ja denen auch nicht, das zu machen. Bloop. Ging das
so? Ging das so? Naja, doch, doch, du kannst ein Endfile machen. Kannst du machen. Ja,
gut. Aber das will ich dir nicht committen. Ah ja, ok. Also, so müssen die Leute das starten.
Die sollen einfach ein Compose File machen. Ich will ihr einfach nur ein Beispiel dabei
schreiben, dass die wissen, wie es geht. Das anpassen dürfen die selbst machen. Das ist
ja nichts, was ich irgendwie großartig supporten will. So, dann haben wir noch Fiat Passwort.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6 und sowas. Genau, wir machen ein Compose Beispiel rein. Ich will einfach
nur mal schauen, ob das jetzt funktioniert. Genau. Ist set, ist set, ist set. Gut, probier
mal aus. Warum willst du denen keinen leeren Endfile? Warum soll ich denen leeren Endfile
machen? Wenn einer das wirklich in dieser unsupporteten Config betreiben will, soll
er das selbst machen. Die sollen gefällig den Addon Manager verwenden, anstatt das selbst
zu laufen zu lassen. Aber nachdem es für mich so eine easy Anpassung ist, dass es überhaupt
möglich ist, dann mache ich das. Aber das supporten will ich nicht. So, jetzt können
wir das ausprobieren. Noch mal einen pullen. Pull. Boom. Big shock. So, jetzt sollte umgedreht.
Genau. Something went wrong. Contacting API. Das ist okay. Wenn ich jetzt sage, minus E,
Standalone. Es war alles groß. Standalone. Klar, ich mach mal einfach mal true. Ist eigentlich
egal, was da drin steht. Dann using Standalone Mode. Okay, das hat schon mal funktioniert.
Nice. Alles klar. Sehr schön. Du bist gerade dazu gekommen. Ich fixe heute ein paar Sachen,
was Issues in meinem GitHub Projekt gibt. True. Und aktuell machen wir gerade das hier.
Also, das hier ist ein Home Assistant Addon, wo du Daten auslesen kannst für dein Elektroauto
oder generell für dein Auto. Zum Beispiel für Fiat funktioniert es, für Jeep funktioniert
es, für Ram und Dodge und Alfa Romeo. Ram und Dodge wusste ich bis zu dem Zeitpunkt
nicht mal, dass es diese Marken überhaupt gibt. Da kannst du so Sachen auslesen wie
Ladestatus und Reifendruck und solche Geschichten oder Batterieladung. Und es gibt Leute, die
wollen zum Beispiel das Addon verwenden als Standalone-Container ohne... Lul. Ohne, dass
sie den Addon Manager verwenden. Und das ist halt ein bisschen blöd. Das funktioniert
nicht. Deswegen habe ich jetzt meinen Startscript gerade angepasst. Und wenn die Leute das eben
hier als Standalone betreiben, dann startet es. Egal, das war es im Prinzip, was wir fixen
müssen. Das sollte eigentlich genügen. Wir müssen jetzt noch kurz überlegen. Wir machen
noch ein Docker-Compose-Beispiel für die Leute. Komm, sind wir mal so nett. Wir machen
noch ein Docker-Compose-Beispiel. Ähm... Compose... Könnte man... Wobei, Leute, wir
machen keine Datei. Wir machen keine Docker-Compose-Datei. Wir machen das in die README. Ich mache
einen README-Eintrag. Fertig. Ich meine, ich lege jetzt zum Testen mal eine Docker-Compose.
Docker-Compose-Example. Ich kann mir immer nicht merken, wie der Krampel aufgebaut ist.
Wir legen den Docker-Compose zum Testen an. Naja, sowas hier in der Richtung. Compose
in die README. Genau. Also, wir machen das jetzt. Also, zack. Version Services. Gut,
das brauchen wir alles nicht. Zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack. So, Image heißt das, glaube
ich. Image. Image. G, H, C. So. Ich hoffe, das funktioniert so. Ports. Tja. Braucht das
Ding Ports? Nee, braucht keine Ports. Ähm, so. Image. Braucht das überhaupt irgendwelche
sonstige Config noch? XFATAL. Danke schön für den Sub. Äh, Environment Variable braucht
das. Docker-Compose-Environment-Variables. Environment-Variables. ENF oder so ist das
hier, glaube ich. Environment. Ja, so. Da. ENVIRONMENT. Jammel. Okay, ENVIRONMENT STANDALONE.
True. True. Lulvee. So, dann brauchen wir noch so Sachen wie Fiat User. Nee. Wir machen
ein Beispiel. Komm, sonst sind die Leute, sonst blicken die Leute überhaupt nicht mehr
durch. Ex, äh, ja. UseratExample.com. Ach so, Services Web. Services. Wir brauchen guten
Namen hier. So. Also Fiat, Fiat PW. 123456. Massive Passwort. Und ansonsten, keine Ahnung,
was ich da sonst noch alles setze. Lass, lass mich das mal kurz nebenbei hier aufmachen.
Was setze ich denn noch alles? Run. Ja. Alter, das hört ja gar nicht mehr auf. Morgen, KS.
Lul. Das muss man alles setzen jetzt. Ich werde verrückt. Okay, nee, also das kann man,
das kann man sich sparen. So. Also Fiat Passwort. Ja. Man kann es doch irgendwie klären, fragt
mich auch nicht, wie das geht. So. Also wir brauchen Fiat User, Fiat PIN. PIN. Keine Ahnung.
999 oder so. Falls, falls überhaupt. Dann brauchen wir Super, Supervisor Token. Da muss ich jetzt
einen Token in meinem Home Assistant generieren. Ah nee, 32, ne? Also ein, ein Exempel müssen
wir dafür machen, bevor ich das pushe. Sonst, sonst checken es, sonst checken es die Leute
eben nicht. So Supervisor Token. Wie macht man das nochmal? Supervisor Token. Irgendwie
hier Token. Lang, lang, ein langlebiges Zugangstoken sollen wir erstellen. Okay, Token Name. Blob.
Exzellent, den da brauchen wir. Kann man nämlich auch gleich sehen, ob der das frisst. Gut.
100 Jahre gültig. Für immer. So, dann haben wir den, dann haben wir den Supervisor Token.
Ah, dann müssen wir diesen ganzen Müll muss man setzen, man. Start Delay in Seconds. One.
So. Dann brauchen wir Region. Region. Da weiß ich noch nicht mal, was ich da reinschreiben
muss, Mensch. Ich glaube Europe ist, wo kann man da reinschreiben? Europe. Ich glaube
Europe oder Amerika steht da drinnen. Region. Brand. Brand. Heard. Car Unknown Location.
Ja gut, ganz ehrlich, wer das von Hand betreiben will, muss ich da halt dann, muss ich dann
halt da drum rum damit auseinandersetzen. Ist nicht mein Problem. Car Unknown Location.
Okay, jetzt haben wir es doch so weit. Ah, hier Convert. Convert Kilometers to Miles.
Jetzt brauchen wir MQTT User. Keine Ahnung, MQTT. MQTT Passwort 123456. MQTT Server. 122.132.
Und MQTT Port. Was ist der Default MQTT Port? 1 7 1837 oder irgendwie sowas. Default Port
131883. So jetzt sollte das so funktionieren.
Ah, Port. Großschreiben, ja. Bin ich ja mal gespannt, ob mein Docker Composer funktioniert.
Ich meine, Login wird nicht funktionieren, aber sollte zumindest mal starten. Warum wurde
ich vom Discord Server gebannt? Ich habe die Diskussion darüber gelesen, aber mach das
mal mit den Mods aus. So, Docker, Compose. Ne. Ab konnte man jetzt machen, gell. Hoho.
Leute, es funktioniert. Ja gut, das ist klar. Invalid Login ID. Invalid Login ID. Doch,
du kannst die Mods im Chat einfach fragen. Sind bestimmt welche da. Also soweit ich
das mitbekommen habe, wurdest du gebannt, weil du glaube ich erst 13 bist oder sowas
und irgendwelche komischen Sachen getrieben hast. So genau habe ich es aber nicht gecheckt.
Ich habe nur die Diskussion gelesen. Ach, Fatal habe ich gar nicht gesehen. Dankeschön
für den Sub. Wie alt muss man für Twitch sein? Ich glaube. Keine Ahnung. Kein Schimmer.
Wahrscheinlich 16 oder so. Mod Check. Discord meistens 13. Also ich kann es dir nicht sagen,
dass wenn einer von den Mods da ist, er könnte sie mir mal erklären. Ich habe es so am Rande
mitgekriegt. Also es funktioniert. Ich meine, das funktioniert nicht, weil meine Login ID
falsch ist. Okay, wir müssen uns jetzt eh gleich einen Fake Account machen. Aber prinzipiell
scheint das zu funktionieren mit Docker Compose. Guckt es euch an. Ich bin begeistert.
Docker Compose scheint zu klappen. Gut. Jetzt ist die Frage, wie ging das nochmal?
Konnte man nicht sowas wie Clean oder sowas machen? Clean? Gab es da nicht was? Nee.
Docker Compose. Down und dann Minus Minus Clean oder irgendwie. Oder egal. Passt. Gut,
hätten wir das schon mal geschafft, dann packen wir das jetzt noch in die Readme rein. Docker
Compose. So und wenn wir das in die Readme reingepackt haben, dann sind wir mit dem ersten
Pull Request, mit dem ersten Issue wahrscheinlich sogar schon durch. Readme. So, wo habe ich
meine Installationen? How to install, follow the official docs. Okay, machen wir hier nochmal
einen Readme Eintrag. Standalone. Code Text war klau. Wie? Was? Warum ist die? Warum ist
die Docker Compose da Teil weg? Set. No Set? Nee. Set. Number? Ausrufe, Zeichen. Meine
Gott. Wim, Alter. Warum auch immer er das dann richtig kopiert hat gerade. So, da schreiben
wir ganz fett dahinter. Not supported and not recommended. Man kann es ja nicht oft
genug sagen, ja. Was schreiben wir da? If you use. Pass auf Englisch, Englisch, Fivehead
Skills Leute, müsst ihr mir jetzt helfen bei. Use Home Assistant as Standalone. In a self
hosted Docker environment oder irgendwie sowas. Envirornment. Das versteht keiner. Was will
ich, was will ich den überhaupt sagen? Sixhead Time. Also. When using Home Assistant. Es
macht einen Link zu dem Issue. Ja, das kann man machen. Wo ist das Issue da? When using
Home Assistant. Was schreibt ihr denn hier? As separate Docker, as self-managed oder sowas.
When this Issue. So. Can use Fiat Champ in Standalone Mode. Standalone Mode. Übrigens
falsch, was ich hier gemacht habe. Nee, ist richtig. Ich habe Standalone auf Two gesetzt.
So, when, when using Home Assistant. Schreiben wir das jetzt noch groß. When using Home Assistant.
As self-managed Docker Container. OK, you can use Fiat Champ in Standalone Mode. OK. Na wunderbar.
So, damit sollten jetzt glaube ich alle glücklich sein, oder? Ob es wirklich funktioniert, muss
ich, muss ich noch rausstellen, aber das kann er ja mal ausprobieren. Guck mal, nee, das
ist die Blume, die haben wir ja. OK, sehr schön. Git, Status. Die Compose File kann
man wieder, wobei ich lasse es nochmal da. Wir müssen es ja nicht committen. Git. Wir
machen noch, wir können noch ein Example dabei schreiben. Ja, sehr schön. Wir können noch
ein Example dabei schreiben, wie das mit Docker Run aussieht. Wobei, ganz ehrlich, scheiß
drauf. Machen wir nicht. In der ReadMe habe ich die Versionsnummer drin. Ja, da kommen
die Leute, sollen sie mal selbst ficken. Nicht ficken, fixen. Selbst ficken sollen
sie es auch, ja. Open Sense unter Proxmox. Was ist damit? Kann man machen. OK. Push.
OK. Sehr schön. Jetzt baut er den Container zwar nochmal neu, nicht dass man das wirklich
bräuchte, aber wir können uns das jetzt mal anschauen, wenn wir das hier umstellen auf
fix. Guck mal, wie die neue ReadMe ausschaut. Install, how to install. Oh. Das ist falsch.
Das soll ein Unterpunkt sein davon, siehste. Schon wieder verkackt. Direkt F. Das soll
ein Unterpunkt sein, also im Prinzip sowas da. Review. Leute, ich mach das noch kleiner.
Wir machen einfach so. Official. Also. Home Assistant, OS. Oh, OK. OK. OK. OK. OK. OK.
OS oder Super Weiß User. Sowas in der Richtung. Oder Super Weiß User.
Home Assistant, Super Weiß. OK, passt. So ist schick, so gefällt mir das. Ja, how
to install Home Assistant, OS oder Super Weiß Standalone, not supported and not recommended.
Das sollte doch jeder so checken, oder? Wenn using Home Assistant als Selbstmord an Stocker
Container like in this issue, you can use FHM in standalone mode. Sehr schön. Ja, nice.
OK, copy paste. Comet changes. Sehr gut. Gefällt mir. So, erstes Issue gefixt. Wunderbar.
Was macht der Fiat-Cham? Da kannst du dein Elektroauto abfragen und Infos in deine Heimautomatisierung
pumpen. Zum Beispiel, was für Batteriestand ist, ob das gerade auflädt, Reifendruck und
solche Geschichten. OK, nice. So erstes Issue gefixt, würde ich sagen. Issue fixed. Running
as Standalone. Standalone is supported in 3.0.4. It released soon. Soon ist immer gut.
Da kannst du immer, wenn dann einer sagt, ja wann ist das denn soweit? Soon. So, dann
kopieren wir den Example. For Docker Compose. Jaml. So, sehr schön. Jetzt kann sich doch
wirklich keiner mit beschweren. Comet. So, habe ich noch irgendwas vergessen? Ich meine,
ich habe meinen Token geleakt, aber es ist egal, das habe ich eh schon wieder gelöscht,
es nur war mir lokal gültig. Habe ich irgendwas vergessen? User. Alter, was ist denn mit der
Musik? Warum ist die so laut? Ich glaube, die ist gar nicht so laut. Hört schon so
laut an. Standalone, Fiat, Passwort, Pin. Hat der hier auch funktioniert? Hat der hier
auch funktioniert? Ab. Docker Compose ab. Nee, funktioniert. Man kann sich nicht einloggen,
die Credentials nicht stimmen oder so, aber das ist okay. Hallo, Max. Gestern war ein
junger Mann vor meiner Tür von der Telekom. Ich frage ihn mal, soll er mal beweisen, dass
er wirklich von der Telekom ist und sagt, ob wir Glasfaser haben wollen, das wäre jetzt
kostenlos und wenn wir es später haben wollen, müssen wir 800 Euro bezahlen. Ja, das kann
durchaus sein. Nee, nee, nee, nee, das kann schon sein. Das kann schon sein. Ich meine,
in einem Mehrfamilienhaus müsste das, das kannst du dir wahrscheinlich nicht alleine
entscheiden. Das stimmt schon. Das stimmt prinzipiell stimmt das schon, das nachträglich
anschließend durchaus was kosten kann. Allerdings ist es ein bisschen fragwürdig, ob da einfach
random ein Telekom Dude vor der Tür steht. Ja, und direkt unterschreiben würde ich da
eh nichts. Die sollen euch Unterlagen zuschicken. Ja, das können die gerne machen. Also prinzipiell
ist das durchaus möglich, dass es später, wenn man sich später anschließen lässt,
dass das teurer wird. Ja, aber da also an der Tür würde ich da schon mal gar nichts
unterschreiben. Die können dir ja Unterlagen zuschicken. Ja, und sag mal so, wenn dir
das Haus nicht gehört beziehungsweise irgendwie keine Eigentumswohnung drin hast, was immer,
dann würde ich da prinzipiell eh schon mal nichts. Kannst ja gar nichts machen. Ja gut,
die sollen aber trotzdem mal Infos zuschicken. Ja, wie das aussieht vom Ausbau her bis wann
das abgeschlossen ist, was die Verträge kosten später und so. Bei Infos braucht man da schon.
Nee, das ist Blödsinn. Dann ist es Scam. Eure Kupferverbindung ist ja nicht weg. Dann ist es
Scam. Du hast nach wie vor in Deutschland ein Recht auf einen Telefonanschluss. Deswegen
kann die Kupferverbindung gar nicht weg sein. Ach, hier guck mal. Die Telekom hat für solche
Fälle eine Authentifizierungshotline eingerichtet. Das ist doch gut. Das ist gut zu wissen. Das
würde ich auch gleich mal machen, dann wenn da einer vor der Tür steht. Guck mal,
Gerald von Riva hat geantwortet. Hat er nicht Besseres zu tun. Aber hier, das ist eine gute Sache.
Das hat die Telekom tatsächlich doch mal schnell geschalten. Warum hat der T-ISDN unten drunter im
Logo? Der hat bestimmt seine Forumsignatur seit 20 Jahren schon. Streame den Anruf? Nö, bestimmt
nicht. Bei mir ist auch kein Glasfaser-Ausbau geplant, das weiß ich. Leider, leider. Bis jetzt.
Drumherum, überall passiert was. Bei mir ist aktuell noch wenig. Gut, hätten wir das Issue
schon mal gefixt. Das ging doch jetzt eigentlich relativ easy und zackig. Next würde ich sagen.
Machen wir weiter. Also, hätten wir das abgehakt? Hätten wir das abgehakt? Nächste Issues. Was machen
wir als nächstes? Das da oder das da? Was ist denn einfacher? Der Dodge. Dodge Login machen wir.
Das Dodge Login funktioniert nicht. Okay, das versuchen wir jetzt mal zu fixen. Das heißt,
wir brauchen auf jeden Fall ein Dodge Fake Account, sonst wird das nichts. So, USA. Das
machen wir mal in einem eigenen Private Tab, sonst habe ich zigtausend Cookies und blicke
nicht mehr durch. 10-Minute-Mail. Wir machen uns ein Fake Account. Wir haben mittlerweile schon
jede Menge Fiat Fake Accounts. Ich habe bestimmt schon 20 Fake Accounts gemacht oder so. Register.
Machen wir das mal in einem eigenen Tab. Okay. United States supported languages English. First
Name. Kackel. Lulve. E-Mail. Next. Passwort. Okay, da muss ich mir jetzt irgendwas ausdenken,
was ich hier gleich noch mal hinschreiben kann. Okay, ich habe was. Oh, come on. Not be included.
Leute, ich wollte einen Underscore rein machen. Underscore ist nicht erlaubt.
Na gut. Next. Ich accepte alles. Wunderbar. Alles accepted. Go to Dashboard. Alles klar. Fake
Account angelegt. Verify your E-Mail. Fiat doesn't know. Die lacken wirklich ganz essentielle
critical information. Also, Status. Das Docker Compose lösche ich mal wieder. Export. Alles
klar. Jetzt muss ich ein paar Sachen exportieren, dass es funktioniert. Weil das, was wir in der
Docker Compose-Datei gemacht haben, muss ich natürlich lokal auch machen, wenn ich lokal
bei mir entwickle. Der muss ja den ganzen Kram gesetzt haben. Also, das da haben wir.
Passwort. MQTT-Server. Export. MQTT. Passwort. Passwort. Warum ist denn das doppelt drin,
der Lule? Export. Fake. ARP. Defmod. Export. Fiat. Convert. Miles. Brand. Und so brauche ich
wahrscheinlich gleich noch, aber ok. Ok, nice. Schauen wir mal, ob das Ganze jetzt funktioniert.
Dotnet. Run. Ob ich alles richtig exportiert habe. Oh nee, das habe ich vergessen. Supervisor
Token. Ah, ich kack noob. Hätte ich es mal nicht gelöscht. Hätte ich es mal nicht gelöscht.
Super. Super. Was muss ich setzen? Supervisor Token is required. Ok. Also. Nochmal das Ganze.
Export. Supervisor. Supervisor Token. Wo soll ich mein Home Assistant wieder aufmachen?
Triggert mich, dass sie sich die richtige IP nicht merkt. Also. Token. Hier. Authentifizierungstoken.
Erstellen. 0W. Copy Paste. Keine Ahnung. Dollar. Supervisor. Was? What the hell? Was willst
du von mir? Das will ich da nicht drin stehen haben, sonst blicke ich da später nicht mehr
durch. Supervisor. Ich hoffe, wir haben es gleich. So. Run. Gucken, ob es jetzt funktioniert.
Run. Ah. Oh. Verbinden Login ID. What? Ok. Das ist doch schon mal genau das Gleiche,
was der hier auch bekommt, oder? Verbinden Login ID. Alles klar. Da sind die URLs falsch.
Ich muss Brand und so noch auf Dodge setzen, glaube ich. Ok. Das kriegen wir raus. Habt
ihr auch Lack? Zeigt mal. Eager Lack. Oh ne. Vodafone. Please. Netschow wieder. 65%
Package Lost bzw. Frame Drops. Geil. Geil. Da hab ich Bock drauf. Da hab ich Bock drauf.
Super. Dankeschön Vodafone. Easy Clap. Sehr gut. Sehr gut. Ja Chat, wir müssen
kurz warten, bis das wieder vorbei ist. Alter, was macht ihr denn wieder? Oh. Ah, haben
sie es geschafft? Haben sie es geschafft? Nope. Wir sind runter auf 44%. Es wird immer
weniger. Es wird immer weniger, Leute. 17%. Ah. Guckt mal, Leute. Scheint wieder zu gehen.
Irgendwie einer über den Router gestolpert. Oder hat aus Versehen das Glasfaserkabel
am Switch bei Wartungsarbeiten abgezogen. We back. Jetzt dürfen die Weeps auch rein.
Stream ist eine halbe Minute 40. Was jetzt hier? Vodafone? Du musst, du musst das wahrscheinlich
refreshen. Beziehungsweise in FFZ den Stream Reload, den Videoplayer resetten. Aber wenn
die Seite Reload ist, dann geht's. Vodafone, please. Ihr seid so ein Kackladen, Mann. Es
ist Schwachsinn. Hört immer auf, so eine Scheiße zu erzählen im Chat, Mann. Es kann
nicht sein, dass du 50, 60, 70 Euro bezahlst und dann gesagt wird, du bist selber schuld,
dass du dahin gehst, dass es ein Internet Provider in Deutschland, der seine Dienstleistung
anbiet und nicht geschissen bekommt. Das hat nichts mit selber schuld zu tun. Das ist einfach
eine Unfähigkeit bei denen. Haben wir es heute noch mal? Ja.
Es ist fast schon auf dem Niveau wie die Bahn, aber das geht nicht. So ein Hass wie auf die
Bahn kann ich, glaube ich, auf nichts anderes wieder schieben. Genau. Ich glaube, sie haben's,
ich glaube, sie haben's geschafft. Ja, sollen sie mal machen. Okay, ich glaube, wir können
weiter machen. Ich glaube, sie haben's geschafft. Okay, wo sind wir stehen geblieben? Supervisor,
Invalid Login ID. Okay, alles. Also, brauchen wir noch, wir brauchen noch ein paar, wir
brauchen noch ein paar mehr Sachen. Wir brauchen noch Brand, Brand ist Dodge, Dodger und wie
habe ich das andere genannt? Region ist, glaube ich, Amerika. So, das wird jetzt immer noch
nicht funktionieren, aber wir sehen schon, es ist Brand 3, Region 1 und es funktioniert
nicht. Jetzt haben wir das schon mal nachgestellt. Immer schön das Warning. Jetzt haben wir das
schon mal nachgestellt. Die Ausgabe sollten wir auch besser machen. Also Brand 3, das
kann ich euch zeigen, was das ist. Brand 3 ist Dodge, 0123. Also Brand 3 ist Dodge und
Region 1 ist Amerika. Das ist schon mal richtig eingestellt. Wir könnten das beim Serialisieren
wahrscheinlich sogar ein bisschen schöner anzeigen lassen. Lass mal kurz schauen. Ich
weiß, wie wir das machen. Und zwar, hier, Program, war da schon, war da schon 14 Tage
nicht mehr drinne. Und zwar, am Anfang, wo ich diesen ganzen Krempel hier ausgebe, Log
Information, To String Without Secrets, da können wir sagen, Serialize Object, New Enum
Serializer oder sowas, wie das hieß, wie heißt denn das? New Enum, oh fuck, wie heißt
denn das? Serializer, meine Güte, das war ich schon aus dem Kopf. Jason.net, Enum, Serializer.
String, String, Enum, Serializer, String, Enum, Converter. So, wenn ich das jetzt richtig
gemacht hab, dann solltet ihr am Anfang zumindest ordentliche Namen ausgeben. Wie der F, oh
nee, oder? Komm mal, jetzt schreibt er Dodge und Amerika. Vodafone, Mann, Alter, kriegt
mal euren Kram hin. Ja, die haben irgendwelche Probleme wieder nachmittags. Ja, was soll
ich da machen? Das wird's sein. Jaja, genau, da steht einer im Rechenzentrum, Kabel rein,
Kabel raus, Kabel rein und guckt auf seinem Smartphone zu und lacht sich kaputt. Wir müssen
da jetzt mit leben, wir können einfach hoffen, dass das jetzt wieder funktioniert. Gut, also
zumindest ist jetzt schonmal eine ordentliche Debug-Ausgabe drin, Brand, Dodge, Region,
und Wasser. Ja, ich hab T, ich hab T hier stehen. Okay, weiter im Text. Das hat ja alles
funktioniert. So, und jetzt müssen wir rausbekommen, was das für URLs verwendet, weil es ist verbinden
mit Invalid Login-ID. Und ich wette mit euch, ich weiß, woran das liegt, nämlich hier dran.
Der guckt, ob Brand Ram Truck ist, hardcoded das auf die USA, das funktioniert, dann guckt
er, ob's Jeep ist, dann unterscheidet er noch Jeep zwischen Europe und US, aber Dodge hat
da gar nicht drinne stehen. Also muss ich quasi machen else if, else if, Brand, gleich gleich,
Dodge. So, und jetzt muss ich das hier ausfüllen, mit Sachen, die ich in den Browser DevTools
rausbekommen kann. Also wir müssen jetzt quasi die richtigen Endpunkte für den Dodge,
für das Dodge Login rausfinden. Also ich geh mal davon aus, dass ich ENUS lassen kann,
das gibt es nur in den USA. Region Endpoint, US East, klingt auch gut, weil Fiat verwendet
für so ziemlich alles US East. Wisst ihr, was wir probieren könnten? Wir könnten einfach
mal probieren, wenn wir die Daten nehmen, die ich schon für Ram Truck, nee, das funktioniert
nicht. Nee, da müsste schon so was wie Jeep drinne stehen. Okay, wir müssen in die DevTools
vom Browser. Also, Network, auf geht's. Müssen wir uns jetzt mal angucken, was hier drinne
passiert. Warum KS? Kann man die Schriftgröße in, ah, dass ihr auch was seht, Leute. Okay,
also wir brauchen die Url für, also wir brauchen den Login APK. Login APK, APK, Login, die
Login-Url. Okay, die Login-Url kriegen wir relativ einfach aus, die Login-Url müsste
ganz hier oben irgendwo drinne stehen. Ach ja, übrigens, es kann durchaus sein, dass
ich mein Passwort leake, aber freut euch nicht zu früh, das ist ein Fake-Account, den ich
eh gleich wieder lösche und wenn ich ihn nicht lösche, ist auch nicht schlimm. Wo
ist das Login? Connect.dodge.com. Seht ihr hier irgendwo ein Login? Login. Hier, Login-US-Dodge.
Da ist der APK. Guck mal, da ist der APK3-ET. Okay, also wir brauchen schon mal Login-US.dodge.com.
Login-US.dodge.com. Okay, dann brauchen wir den Login-APK. Login-APK, APK, APK, APK,
APK, MKS. Was, wie, AP? Jetzt hört es aber auf. Nee, wo ist der APK? APK, ja. Ja,
ja. Wobei ich mir da gar nicht sicher bin. Okay, ich muss mal kurz schauen, wo wir das
brauchen. Okay, von der Länge her kommt das schon mal hin. Login-APK, wo benutze ich den
denn hier? Und zwar Web SDK Bootstrap. Ah, die verwenden das gar nicht. Ah, sehr schön.
Natürlich auch geil. Mal gucken, mal gucken, ob wir schon weiter kommen jetzt. Ah, wie,
das hat jetzt einfach funktioniert. Moment, mehr muss ich nicht anpassen, das war es schon.
Moment, Moment. What? Da stimmt irgendwas net. Okay, ich schreibe jetzt mal irgendeinen
14 rein. Ja, das funktioniert nämlich net. Ja, ist ja gut. Mensch, hör auf. Kommen denn
auch gescheite Daten raus? Das weiß ich nicht, ich habe ja da kein Auto drinne registriert.
Aber gut, Leute, wisst ihr, das kann durchaus sein, dass das funktioniert. Ich meine, aus
irgendwelchen Gründen geht der APK vom anderen auch, aber okay. Das ist der APK für die
Tokens. Das kann durchaus sein, dass das okay, wir können nochmal, wir gucken nochmal hier.
Jason Web Token, Login, Get Jason Web Token. Wo ist der, wo ist das, wo ist der APK? Request?
Okay, da brauchen wir hier gar nichts. Ich glaube, das ist richtig. Wir können das auch
switchen, ja. So, Login, APK. Und wo kommt der normale, wo kommt der normale APK jetzt
ins Spiel? Identity Response. Ah ja, das andere ist der, das andere ist der Amazon APK. Ja,
das kann tatsächlich sein, dass es der gleiche ist. Das kann tatsächlich sein, dass es
der gleiche ist hier, weil es ist ja US East und das ist auch US East. Ist wieder am Rucke?
Ey Leute, ich kann da wirklich gar nichts dran ändern, wo davon ist am Rumspacken? Okay,
wo ist der, wo ist der Amazon, wo ist der Amazon Request? Wo ist der, wo ist der Amazon Request?
Connect, Dodge. Hallo? Wie? Möchtest gerne resizen. Connect, Dodge, hier, CDN, US1,
APK. Ist es doch? 4D? Nee, das kann ja nicht sein. Das kann ja nicht sein. APK. Identity
Response. Doch, oder? Talking World. Ach nee, das muss irgendwie an Outs, an Outs gehen.
Den Request brauche ich. Outs. Ja, Fetch. APK. Da, das ist der Richt, das ist der gleiche,
hier, guck mal. Das ist der gleiche, deswegen geht das auch. Das ist der gleiche Key, die
verwenden, okay, Dodge und Ramtruck verwenden den gleichen Amazon APK, der funktioniert,
weil es der gleiche Amazon Endpunkt ist. Okay, das ergibt Sinn. So, und jetzt ist noch die
Frage, ob wir diesen gleichen Multi-Faktor-Authentifizierungs-Ul verwenden? Gar nicht? Okay. Oh, ich hab nichts
gesagt. Ach so, das ist für die PIN-Eingabe, gut, das ist eh schonmal ekel. Channels. Ja,
ist auch das gleiche. Ja, kein Wunder, dass das funktioniert. Also, im Prinzip das Einzige,
was ich ändern musste in dem Fall ist tatsächlich die Login-Ul. Die AP ist zwar angeblich eine
andere, aber, naja. Oder auch nicht, naja. Warte mal, Login-Ul bei Dodge war das da.
Ah ja, ich will mich jetzt ja mal nicht beschweren, dass es funktioniert. Also anscheinend ist
das alles, was man an Anpassung braucht. Okay. Ja, wir können sogar prüfen, ob das funktioniert.
Und zwar, Login, wo ruft er sich die Autos ab? Wir fixen ein paar GitHub-Issues von meinem
Home Assistant Addon. Ich war da jetzt aber schon 14 Tage nicht mehr drin. Hier, da, da
müssen wir hin. Hier, Vehicle-Response-Palmer. Ey, wir brauchen nicht die Vehicle-Response,
die gibt es ja gar nicht. Wir brauchen Login. Login, hier. Stage? Das hier, doch, das hier
brauchen wir. Log, Vehicle-Response, zack. Da sollte jetzt ein leeres Array rauskommen.
Ja, funktioniert, guckt. Ich meine, ich habe keine Autos registriert auf dem Account, das
ist ja logisch, dass er keine Autos findet. Aber es funktioniert. Ich würde sagen, zweites
Issue gefixt, easy. Nee, das war jetzt tatsächlich relativ einfach, gar nicht gedacht. Was hat
Fiat mit anderen Automarken zu tun? Weil Fiat, Chrysler, Dodge, Jeep und Ram alles irgendwie
der gleiche Laden ist. Und die verwenden auch die gleichen Services, nur, dass sie unterscheiden
zwischen EU, Asien und Amerika. Da sind die Settings anders. Ansonsten ist es rein von
den, also mal von den Endpunkten abgesehen, macht es keinen Unterschied. Also intern funktionieren
die Sachen gleich, egal ob Fiat, Chrysler oder Dodge oder Alfa Romeo oder sowas, das
funktioniert intern alles ähnlich. Man muss nur sich die richtigen URLs raussuchen, wo
er hinconnectet. Also sprich, man muss nur gucken, welche Automarke in welcher Region
welche Settings braucht. Wir können das tatsächlich switchen oder Leute, oder wir machen das sogar
ein bisschen ordentlicher. Entweder machen wir das so oder, wisst ihr was vielleicht
noch besser wäre, dass man den Kram vielleicht auch noch mal in einem Jahr wieder lesen kann.
Oder, anstatt hier in diesem Fiat Client diesen ganzen Mist reinzupacken, könnte man auch
sowas hier machen. Public, Class, Fiat Client Options oder sowas. Und da machen wir den
ganzen Kempel rein. Dann übergibt man das nämlich nur einmal beim Anlegen und da kann
man sich auch Region und sowas hier alles sparen. Ich glaube das ist gar nicht so verkehrt.
Da kann man das nämlich hier alles rausschmeißen und packt das hier in diese Optionsklasse
rein. Ich glaube das ist die bessere Variante. Also im Prinzip, als man das hier jetzt nimmt,
hat Ryder sowas als ich ein Property draus machen kann. Alter Ryder ist wirklich sehr
Sixhead muss man sagen. Ryder ist wirklich High IQ Software. Da kann man sich nicht beschweren.
Schaut euch das mal an. Da hätte ich jetzt wieder 5 Minuten rum gemacht. Gut. So. Und
jetzt packen wir nämlich diesen ganzen anderen Krempel hier rein. Also das sind die Default
Settings. Ist die Playlist zu Ende? Das sind die Default Settings. Das sind halt die Default
Settings für Fiat im Endeffekt. Dann können wir nämlich, ok Endpoint kommt auch noch hier
rein. Endpoint. Region. Und User. Können wir natürlich auch reinpacken. Och nett Schau
wieder. Mann Vodafone ihr geht mir auf den Sack. Leute soll ich den Streamer ausmachen
und einen anderen Twitch Server benutzen? Vielleicht hat ja nur der Twitch Server wieder
Probleme hier und den da standardmäßig verwendet. Ich nehme mal den Twitch Server in Amsterdam.
Wir probieren mal aus ob das geht. Ich bin gleich wieder da. Ich bin gleich wieder da
Leute. Ich mache jetzt Stopp und ich bin in 30 Sekunden oder so könnt ihr den Stream
refreshen. Da bin ich wieder da. Und ich wähle mal einen anderen Twitch Server aus. Vielleicht